I watched the Thor movie and I'm saying
wasn't hammerway and I heard a sentence
in the movie that enabled me to
calculate how much his hammer weighed
they say hammer forged in the heart of a
Dying star oh my gosh I'm an
astrophysicist we deal in dying Stars I
got this hide some dense stuff going on
in a dying star I filled out the density
and I tweeted it and I said if Thor's
hammer is made in the way the movie says
it has the weight of a herd of 300
million elephants that's why nobody
could pick it up the Hulk couldn't pick
it up you need the magical powers of
Thor to do it but watch what happened I
tweeted that out and then I got out
nerded somebody said Dr Tyson is wrong
about this calculation I got totally
smoked on this one so what happened was
in 1991 Marvel issued a Thor's hammer
trading card where they said Thor's
hammer is made of a fictional material
uru and it weighs precisely 42.3 pounds
so they kind of cheated but I wanted my
answer to be true I think it's a way
better answer
that 42.3 pounds but it's wrong